[Music]
welcome back it's time now for our
mornings with metro segment today we're
joined by assistant sheriff andrew walsh
thanks again for being here thanks for
having me back all right love the chats
earlier this summer now we talked to the
sheriff
and about a new initiative to try and
bring down the numbers of stolen cars in
the valley uh and even recently we saw a
man held at gunpoint to steal his car
out of his garage that was running with
the ac on what's what's the latest with
this it's the most frustrating crime if
you're a citizen right if you come out
of your house and go to work and your
car is gone
even worse to have somebody put a gun to
your head and take your car but uh
no since we uh uh
since the sheriff spoke about it we've
seen about a 10 increase every decrease
everyone say decreased 10 decrease every
month in uh stolen cars
but we you know look for the patterns
and trends associated with people
stealing and there's different reasons
for stealing a car some it's just basic
transportation or joyriding but what's
the best advice you can give people
about maybe avoiding getting their cars
stolen not leaving it out there yeah you
know one thing that's uh interesting is
uh
we we see many times people still leave
their keys in the car or leave the car
running one of the advantages in
technology the push button technology in
a car people sometimes forget that they
leave the key fob in in the car so that
that just a crime of opportunity
but the other thing is you know if you
have a garage if you have the luxury of
owning a home or an apartment that has a
garage
you know think the garage is not just
for storage you know get rid of some of
your stuff and put your car in the
garage it's safer there well we're
seeking more emphasis so change the
subject here on recruiting and diversity
efforts at metro and you just promoted
your first female african-american
lieutenant corrections officer tell us a
little bit about lieutenant cherie
butler you know
it's a great story because you know
obviously the first of anything is
something we should celebrate and you
know cherie being the first black female
lieutenant that we have in the clark
county detention center really is a
testament to
her success and her career but you know
it's not an easy thing to even uh
promote uh for any any of us and uh you
know she's worked hard at it and it's
something that's been a career goal for
her and
but i think it does a couple things one
is uh it tells people that your goals
and your dreams within metro are
attainable but also tells people that
are thinking about joining the police
department that
regardless of where you come from what
you look like
there's opportunities for you to promote
within
and we encourage that diversity
in
in our organization well we appreciate
that and we wish you luck we know that
it's a tough job it's a dangerous job
and we've we see that every day with the
stories that we cover right here so uh
your own story you've been with the
department how long july 27th made 23
years wow
congratulations so yeah it's been a good
uh it's been a good run i've been very
fortunate to uh
um to work here i moved here from uh new
york you know with uh she was my
girlfriend at the time she's my wife now
and uh they asked her it was her idea to
move here not mine but she made an
honest man out of you oh yeah
well thank you so much for being with us
and new york's lost our game we
appreciate that i appreciate that
assistant sheriff andrew walsh if you
have a question for metro police you can
submit it on our website
eightnewsnow.com find out if your
question was answered every wednesday
during mornings with metro